for those of you who don't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel
with a hundred and eighty thousand
subscribers mind you I'm pretty proud of
that achievement even though I haven't
really posted anything for last several
years a few videos that I made on that
channel several years ago have been
stolen and used in an ad campaign for an
app called video dot me it's a video
editing app for your phone and I've
never used the app I have no idea how
good it is but what I do know is that
they're using a few videos of mine to
demonstrate what their app is capable of
and frankly that's you've waited more
than three seconds you'll have to look
at sometimes with writing you hit these
moments where you're like oh well I feel
like something strong but I don't know
what is wrong that's when it's good to
open it up to other people brand
integrations right what if we took world
the tanks and instead of it being like a
gun battle between tanks in a field it's
someone going to buy a tank in the same
way that you buy a car there is like a
suburban couple that's buying a tank
from salesman just in the same way that
you buy a car it's like buying a car but
tank ha so it's a little bit repetitive
and so the same joke kind of over and
over I think the setting that you guys
need to tweak to make it work is that
you got to take the family out of it
replace it with like the actual ageneral
it's nonsensical that it's like a
husband and wife shopping for tanks and
it actually takes away from the jokes
because if you literally just take it
family buy a car and you solve it for
tanks versus like taking the whole
setting to be the general and maybe the
subordinate are going to buy tanks for
their military juxtapose the whole scene
of the salesman saying family it's I
think it's way funnier to see the
interaction between generals and arms
dealers as exactly the same as a family
buying a car unfortunately there's a
bigger problem with the script and that
is that your characters don't have any
goals so how are you guys gonna fix that
what are you going to do to make this
better
so rule there's a freaking cool down man
it's three seconds you got three seconds
to call me out and you did not kill him
okay Elvis I was really hesitant to talk
about this on camera but Nico was like
no I think our viewers would really like
to know what you think about this cuz
honestly I'm not happy about it cuz
first off they're just straight-up
ripping my video I was never contacted
all the ad money that they're spending
none of that is coming my way which I'm
not opposed to licensing my videos for
other people to use but don't just steal
my content and use it for your own
financial gain basically it's an
Instagram ad so if you're using
Instagram and you happen to have seen my
face it looks like this it's company
called sunji mobile and the running and
Instagram ad campaign using two of my
videos one is where I create fire in my
hand and I move it around that is
something that was actually fairly
complicated created that all from
scratch I didn't follow in tutorials for
it so I made my own tutorial on how to
do it and I was really proud of it and
here's this company claiming that you
can do that using their app I don't
believe them i straight-up just don't
believe that I mean eventually that'll
be possible I'm not saying that you
can't do with an app what I did on
visual effects the like that gap is very
quickly closing upon thinking about this
it's like alright who do I contact to
either stop this or negotiate some sort
of backlogged fee for them using my
content I didn't find any easy way to
report them on Instagram because if you
go up to report it's only like it's
inappropriate or it's spam neither of
which applies to this situation right
now you have characters here that don't
want text let's admit it's a man and a
wife or the family those people don't
want to take there's no problem that the
salesman is trying to get around to
cells guys that's I think the other
thing inherent problem in the grips is
we need a point of reference that that
they have so that when the salesman
leapfrogs them it has context yeah when
you skin them as a general or someone in
the military you don't need to actually
ever question why's 2/3 that's a
slightly different point you don't need
to understand that a general wants a
tank a general oxygen that's that's a
given but if the salesman is going to
switch out the tanks on him why does
that matter and that's where you need
the why what kind of tank is he
more give him a reason why he wanted me
probably not is on the nose it's like
all of our things got blown up so we
need this kind it's like a general of a
country that doesn't have an army and so
they're laughingstock he's like I'm
gonna show them the coolest okay
everyone's gonna think oh yeah he's
defenseless no he's got a cool thing
we're not gonna invade do the imagining
for the audience accomplish something
creative and fun character based comedy
base because then you also get the
salesman a problem to deal with which is
I've got to get rid this accountant and
like I would just get rid of him right
away I constantly have to be something
has to deal with the entire video yeah I
like that see a clear source of conflict
throughout the entire thing if you want
to start it off with the general looking
at this tense like it's perfect it's
like what I'm only gonna get this
opportunity once it's my money well this
is for the people okay if I don't get
this ten I'm just gonna sit here we're
creating it for the next five years like
we're here let's get a tank we're
expecting more after we take power we've
been trying for a third row we turn it's
gonna be Special Forces he's right in
the script already and I believe you
guys shoot this in a way a very very
Freddy W style it's like you have your
establishing shot and then like you have
here three or four visual gig and then
you have your like your ending shot and
that's yeah not tracking and it's not a
focused stuff in the background every
day looks wrong she's shoot the dialogue
shots with like the CG tank always in
the back we need a shot where they climb
onto the CG tank
I can't tell Kevin I'm not joking
anymore next up mountains for real yeah
that's not gonna work if you wanted to
be a CG King I just decide last minute
whether I'm joking or not and I started
that one off not joking and then I was
like you know what I should probably be
joking about this how many battalions oh
we have to and armor did an infantry oh
that's great yeah we've been trying for
a third but are waiting until we take
full power I think don't be back we have
to wear helmets they need extra
that's the reason for going for a third
[Laughter]
rent is going to play all three roles we
should do one more script from the
ground up at the st. Croix Valley press
this is the st. Croix Valley press no no
from White Bear Lake Minnesota State
January 8 2009 the reason I brought this
piece of newspaper here is because the
our founders painting funny super funny
and I just I had to bring in something
here that brings a little context to
this whole thing because on the onset it
can look very egotistical they were like
yes we want the little paintings of
ourselves that image was photographed by
my mother and like almost 10 years ago
right before we moved to LA originally
when I put it up here it's it was just
as a joke yeah somebody like on Twitter
or somewhere you found it online and
then send it to us and I was like oh
yeah I remember that and so so this is
ed those that was a photo that was taken
by my mom like almost 10 years ago
before we moved to LA when we were still
making like funny short films you know
in the Midwest and that particular photo
was used in the local newspapers
Hollywood filmmakers hail from
Stillwater I know this is like ultimate
small-town fame here the former students
delight in special effects great we
aren't posing
lay back chillax the st. croix Valley
Press profiling the people places and
events that shape the st. croix Valley
Thursday January 8th 2009 so it's funny
because like the day before we got all
the paintings I'm sent this to me and
there you go look at that filmmakers
honed their skills and Stillwater
classroom Sam Gorski a new comparator
shop the first film quote-unquote
infected for $55,000 Wow spilling the
beans right there come on it's our first
movie that has not lost money love
hard-boiled if things go well infected
will be available at Best Buy and you
can buy it I did buy it
Brenda the movie the movie sucks but
it's really funny if you watch it with
us it's awesome it's poor conditions
British Columbia was beautiful for
filming for you you couldn't filming
conditions so rain and stuff oh those
yeah yeah
you couldn't point the camera and get a
bad shot Gorsky recalled yeah Hong Kong
action movies are about the physicality
and realness of things as opposed to CG
and fast editing comparing percent the
American action movie isn't fleshed out
and it doesn't show devotion to making
things good that's right hard at quotes
little did he know that you guys your
career would be and that's the shortcut
that cynicism as has has has been Niko's
defining outlook to this very day he
hasn't changed a bit using words like
good and bad oh yes originally slated to
cost $30,000 Gorsky and Perry Harris
producers decided to ramp the budget up
after two weeks of quality shooting
aerial shots were budgeted in and well
this is this is this is actually
inaccurate they should issue a an update
and pairing gear found himself suspended
out of an open airplane trying to shoot
landscape footage it was me [ __ ] yeah
pre drones when you literally point the
camera outside of a plane
yeah fun fun times anyways what so this
came out in January of 2009 that was the
month that I discovered After Effects I
kind of stuff that I keep getting from
my dad in the mail like small-town
filmmakers and even is like you know
these guys know them they're from the
town you live in now which I've never
lived in number one number two this is
like some 16 year olds that want a local
film festival not that this is the same
thing I have been getting tons of
messages on both Instagram and Twitter
and email from people me like hey is
this you I've been called a sellout from
me letting them use my videos so they're
assuming that I'm making money from that
but the reality is I'm not I have a
feeling it might be from some sort of
old screen classic so I'm partnered with
this company called full screen which is
a multi-channel network so I've reached
out to full screen to see if they can
have any power for like shutting that
down and if I continue to not hear from
them I'll I'll continue discussing with
Jake wood what my options are I took a
screenshot right so here's the the app
it's literally that's I feel Melissa put
this on my channel like literally six
years ago from a Instagram called some
sunji mobile they're running out to take
a new video every day yeah see you
Tony's a random mobile company just
stole a bunch of your content I don't I
mean yeah are you gonna like get a huge
settlement
yes and and there's no way to like go to
their channel page or well the first
thing you should do this
which I have I haven't heard that this
was ticket fix thank suited summary
mobile do those thieves are bad good
liars
so I've never personally seen this in
the wild I think they might be white
listening my channel to not see it so I
don't notice it but many people on
Instagram are getting that as an ad like
you know when you're going through just
your regular Instagram feed because
someone messaged it to me just the share
button and I assume you're ready Google
search seungji Mobile Instagram give
them a URL see exactly and that's why I
was like I don't know how to proceed
from here cuz I can't get a URL we've
submitted enough copyright reports where
we've gotten direct emails from them cuz
I could try to send it to those emails
and go hey you know that this
infringement is happening and it's
they're circumventing your copyright
system by placing it as mad another
thing to do would be to reach directly
out to somebody mobile so just to
reiterate here's the problem
Instagram allows for a copyright report
form so that if somebody posts a video
of yours you can send them the URL of
that video and of your video and have
that video taken down
we do on Facebook but here's the problem
that we just encountered that I don't I
haven't seen before
this company Sony Mobile took wrens
video put it in their ad and then paid
for that ad to be posted on Instagram so
there's no way to capture the URL
because it's being run through an
algorithmic ad so you can't report it in
this way and as far as we know there's
no formalized system of reporting this
way I doubt I doubt that fullscreen has
anything to do with this there's some
pretty shady MTN's out there but I don't
know if any of them allow for them to
use your content in ads without your
permission
yeah no don't wait for force right yeah
no don't wait for fullscreen you need to
put a kibosh on this now
and when you do inform Instagram over
this one potential problem so who do I
message Instagram so that's what you've
got to do man